from ten to seven to five and now for
the Conservative candidate countdown
continues the following candidates are
now eligible to continue on to the next
ballot on Thursday 20th of June at 10:00
a.m.
Michael Gove Jeremy Hunt
Sajid Javid and Boris Johnson
commiserations for the insurgent war
which doeth to left-field in the end as
he leaves this contest he thinks reality
is leaving to the one Canada in this
race who said you're not going to get
another deal out of the European Union
by the end of October by the end of
December has been removed for this race
my judgment my professional considered
judgment is that what I said was true we
will now see between now and the end of
October whether people can deliver what
they promised and my instinct is they
can't scraping in by whisker the Home
Secretary Sajid Javid vowing tonight to
fight on in the knowledge his race is
probably now run you are now probably
going to get knocked out in short order
tomorrow lunchtime is that any benefit
for you into folding into Boris
Johnson's camp now in return for being I
don't know his Chancellor I'm in this to
win it and so you know what you've just
said that's what everyone was saying
laughs Simon look where I am now
so just to be clear you are not going to
pull out of this race I'm not pulling
out I'm gonna carry on going as long as
I have the support of my colleagues he's
hanging in but Boris Johnson is pulling
away every day brings him closer to
number 10 he is streets ahead but his
rivals and even some of his supporters
are adamant this shouldn't be a
coronation because the next PM has a
momentous task ahead they desperately
need a mandate not just from MPs but
from the wider party too
tomorrow MPs will follow up these stats
once again to finally decide who out of
Jeremy Hunt Michael Gove and Sajid Javid
should take on Boris Johnson in the
battle for number 10 team hunt will be
hoping that those who supported Rory
Stewart will break for them but in
reality this race has been so fluid and
unpredictable it's still all on in the
final rounds and whoever does win out
then faces the very daunting task of
trying to beat Boris Johnson with the
party membership Boris Johnson's
birthday today a happy one but the
scrutiny and the taunts will only
intensify from now on tough questions
and giant chickens will follow mr.
Johnson until he answers them his rivals
won't be giving him an easy ride bath
Rigby Sky News Westminster